I think I'm going to answer where do you
fall short in these 12 rules is it a
cause constant adjustment you know like
I wrote these rules why did I write
these rules well you know and especially
when I said well you should try to
improve yourself instead of trying to
set the world straight or instead of
worrying about what other people are
doing wrong you might say well that's a
hell of a thing for someone to say you
just wrote a book called 12 rules for
life it's like you know but the thing is
is that I wasn't just writing that I was
writing that for me as much as for
anyone else and I mean that's really
mean that sincerely you know I had an
opportunity to spend somewhere around
five years meditating on how you should
conduct yourself so that your life is
what it could be and like I'm in the
group of people that I'm advising you
know you know what I mean it's like all
of these things are very difficult to
stand up straight to remember that and
to treat yourself like you're someone
worthwhile and to make friends with
people who are good for you and and and
to tell the truth or at least not to lie
I mean these are all ideals right and
especially taken as a whole they
constitute a kind of ideal and you never
approve you never you never attain the
ideal the I and not only that it recedes
as you approach it right because you
straighten yourself out you think well
I've got it now and you think now wait a
minute there's more to go there's still
more to go and then you get that much
farther along the line you think oh yeah
I thought this was the end of the road
it's like no there's plenty of
imperfections left to iron out and so it
is a constant adjustment and but there's
something about that that's also
positive because you might say that it's
not so much that there isn't such a
thing as a good person it's that our
idea of what constitutes good isn't
right because a good person is someone
who's trying to get better and no matter
how good you are there's better that you
can get but the real goodness is in the
attempt right it's in the it's in the
process to use somewhat of a cliche you
know there's this I know I'll close with
this and it's a good way to close you
know and this is a psychological
observation the the central figure of
Western culture is Christ
and we can look at that psychologically
because Christ is the dying and
resurrecting hero and what does that
mean psychologically well it means that
you learn things painfully and when you
learn something painfully a part of you
has to die
that's the pain you know when a dream is
shattered for example a huge part of you
that constituted that dream maybe even
the biological substrate of that gene
has to be stripped away and burned and
so life is a constant process of death
and rebirth and to participate in that
fully is to allow yourself to be
redeemed by it and so the good is that
process of death and rebirth voluntarily
undertaken it's like you're not as good
as you could be so you let that part of
you die and if someone comes along and
says you know there's some dead wood
here man it needs to be burned off you
think well that stuff's still a bit
alive when that burns it's gonna hurt
it's like yeah well no kidding
but maybe the thing that emerges in its
place is something better and I think
this is the secret of human beings this
is what we're like you know unlike any
other creature is that we can let our
old selves die and let our new selves be
born and that's what we should do and so
where do I fall short in these twelve
rules well endlessly because well here's
a way of thinking about it until the
entire world is redeemed we all fall
short and that's probably a good place
to stop
you
[Applause]